rusia está atacando las rutas y la
infraestructura que tiene este país para
almacenar y distribuir todo ese
armamento pesado que le llega de sus
aliados occidentales en las últimas
horas se ha atacado puntos estratégicos
como es la red ferroviaria y depósitos
de armas mientras la guerra del donbass
continúa hay pequeños avances de las
tropas rusas en el este todos los
ataques con artillería se están
centrando allí pero también en el sur en
gerson donde las tropas rusas intentan
alcanzar nuevos territorios de momento
en gerson controlan la principal ciudad
donde hay cientos de ciudadanos que
están intentando salir pero que no
pueden porque esa ciudad está controlada
por el ejército ruso y noticias
preocupantes también de la zona noreste
de este país en hardcore hay movimientos
de tropas rusas en esa frontera en la
ciudad de bélgorod han llegado dos
nuevos batallones rusos tácticos y
también misiles de medio alcance con un
alcance de hasta 500 kilómetros lo que
significa que incluso podrían llegar
en esa ciudad rusa se han escuchado las
últimas horas varias explosiones que al
parecer son depósitos de gasolina